Géopolitique, Marie-France
Chatin. En 2011, le peuple
égyptien se soulevait contre la
dictature suivant la vague des
printemps arabes après de
premières élections libres
suivies d'un coup d'État, cela
fait 10 ans que le maréchal
Sissi s'affirme comme l'homme
fort de l'Égypte sur fond de
guerre contre le terrorisme et
de répression implacable.
Aujourd'hui le pays se
fragilise économiquement sur
tout. Géopolitique,
Marie-France Chatin. Samedi à
partir de dix-huit heures
quarante-et-une. RFI. Rfi et
France 24 présentent
Radio Foot International, le
Café des Sports, Annie Gasnier.
Bonjour à tous, bienvenue dans
ce Café des Sports euh, un café
des sports qui euh, rime eh
bien avec départ en vacances
puisque c'est notre dernière
apparition de la saison, nous
serons là évidemment l'année
prochaine euh, fidèle au
rendez-vous mais pour l'instant
on va vous offrir euh, un mois
de de vacances de
désintoxication du football
euh, vous pourrez faire autre
chose, lire des livres écoutez
RFI il y aura d'autres
programmes bien sûr à notre
horaire mais eux ils sont
fidèles jusqu'au bout et euh,
notamment euh, celui qui qui a
à à prendre ses marques dans le
le Café des Sports, le de
20dix7, bonjour euh Benjamin
Moukonjo. Bonjour Annie,
bonjour à tous. Merci mille
fois de nous faire l'amitié
d'être dans Radio Foot
International et d'être
régulièrement dans le Café des
Sports. C'est surtout un
plaisir pour moi d'être là. On
adore, et nos auditeurs adorent
je peux vous le dire puisque
quand on lit leurs réactions
sur la page Facebook, c'est
toujours euh très élogieux à
votre rencontre. Alors il y a
aussi évidemment le duo de
choc, toujours là, toujours
présent, toujours fidèle au
rendez-vous euh du bleu ciel
contre du marron
franchement une très belle
année qu'on va fêter comme il
se doit. Et bonjour euh Xavier
je vous ai dit cet homme il a
possédé Xavier
Bonjour Frédéric. Bonjour
Annie. Bon alors Frédéric hein,
il conclut sa première saison
entière avec euh avec le Café
des Sports, ça va? Ouais mais
je suis pas tout seul.
Vous avez du Voilà. Ben il
préfère la petite balle jaune
parfois mais on peut pas lui en
vouloir. Alors dans les débats
du jour euh plein de choses
encore, on a réussi à trouver
des bons thèmes pour vous
aujourd'hui. Et nous parlerons
de Sadio Mané. Sadio Mané qui
voit rouge, qui voit toujours
rouge. La star du foot euh
sénégalais a déclaré durant ses
vacances au pays qu'il va bien
rentrer au Bayern, Munich. Le
club où il vient de la saison.
Quel bilan dressé de sa
première année bavaroise? La
Coupe du monde féminine c'est
pour bientôt coup d'envoi du
Mondial le 20 juillet à
Auckland en lice 32 équipes,
quelques stars internationales
comme euh la brésilienne Martha
qui disputera sa sixième Coupe
du monde ou l'autre euh vétéran
que l'américaine Meghan Ropino
qui rêve de réaliser le triplé
avec la team USA.
Une
saison pas comme les autres
avec cette première Coupe du
monde en hiver juste avant
Noël, que faut-il retenir?
Qu'avez-vous retenu? Eh bien
nous parlerons sans doute
Ballon d'or, nous parlerons
aussi du départ des stars euh
Messi et Cristiano de de ce
championnat et d'autres thèmes
qui ont marqué la saison 2022,
20vingt-trois. Au générique de
cette émission donc tous ceux
qui autour de moi préparent et
euh réalisent cette émission,
David Finzel, Pierre Guérin et
Laurence All et puis il y a
aussi et Yann le Café des
Sports et les débats sont
ouverts.
Si tout va bien, je vais
retourner voir inchallah. On va
essayer de se battre tous
ensemble pour pouvoir aider le
club à atteindre ses objectifs
euh la saison prochaine.
Aime-t-il la Bavière, l'enfant
de Bambali? En tout cas pour
ses premières vacances après
euh sa saison au Bayern Munich,
il est rentré se ressourcer au
Sénégal, bien sûr. Cette
première année n'a pas été sans
doute celle qu'il imaginait,
n'a pas été aussi simple. Pour
l'ancien joueur de Liverpool,
évidemment, c'est euh la grave
blessure qu'il a euh subie, qui
l'a privée deux coupes du
monde, avec les Lions de la
Teranga. Il y a aussi eu dans
son club un changement
d'entraîneur, une embrouille
avec un camarade jeu, bref,
mais il ne se résigne pas
évidemment, le lion, il va
retourner au Bayern. C'est ce
qu'il a déclaré sur une chaîne
euh sénégalaise euh cette
semaine, alors qu'il visitait
euh des certaines des
installations hein qu'il
finance pour des enfants de de
Bambali. C'était à Dakar,
d'ailleurs, si je me trompe
pas. Est-ce qu'il a raison? Euh
je je m'adresse évidemment à
l'ancien joueur euh de se dire
j'y retourne et je persévère.
Il a raison parce que d'autant
plus qu'on en parlait euh ici,
et moi je disais que si Sadio
Mané était appelé à partir
après euh une saison euh
difficile, c'était un peu pour
moi un aveu d'échec. Et tel
qu'on connaît Sadio Mané qui
est un joueur euh bien sûr à
fort potentiel et qui a surtout
envie de relever les défis
parce qu'il en a relevé hein
tout au long de sa carrière eh
ben de venir euh au Bayern avec
euh notamment ce que vous
disiez Annie, euh tout ce qu'il
a connu euh il y a aussi la
malchance parce que s'est
blessé euh on envisage pas
souvent mais ça arrive, il a
manqué cette coupe du monde et
puis derrière euh moi
m'interroge un peu plus c'est
son positionnement cette saison
euh quand il arrive au Bayern.
Ça l'a pas beaucoup aidé, le
fait de l'avoir de l'avoir mis
devant avec et essayer de
rectifier un peu les tirs et
puis il y a eu cette
embrouille-là, il y a beaucoup
de choses qui se sont passées
pour Sadio Mané mais pour moi
c'est un grand champion qui
sait ce qu'il faut pour
rebondir donc pour moi oui
c'est bien qu'il reste au Baen
pour prouver une fois de plus
qu'il a sa place dans cette
équipe et qu'il peut apporter
quelque chose pour leur
permettre de gagner parce que
quoi qu'il arrive ils n'ont
gagné que le championnat cette
année d'Allemagne. Oui voilà
c'est c'est ça c'est c'est pour
du beurre ça. Elle est oui les
Parisiens ils comptent toujours
euh le le trophée des
champions. Euh Xavier euh il a
on l'a dit hein il a été blessé
mais il a quand même joué
trente-huit matchs marqué douze
buts euh fait six passes
décisives et son contrat va
jusqu'en deux-mille-vingt-cinq.
Alors l'année a été compliquée
non seulement pour lui
physiquement mais autour de lui
dans dans ce vestiaire euh ce
changement d'entraîneur il y a
eu plein de choses euh
finalement on n'a peut-être pas
vu le Sadio Mané qui qui qu'on
oui parce que je crois que
c'est cette euh ce défi, il a
commencé sur un malentendu en
fait. Le le Bayern devait euh
recruter un avant-centre pour
remplacer euh euh Lewandowski
qui partait à Barcelone, et et
euh et donc du coup euh ben ils
ont pris Sadio Mané qui était
en quête d'un nouveau défi
après euh cette saison à à
Liverpool mais euh c'était
c'est pas vraiment un
avant-centre, enfin c'est pas
en tout cas le poste dans
lequel il s'en se sent le plus
à l'aise c'est le Bayern qui
s'est trompé de d'une certaine
façon. Bah un peu les deux
parce que personne l'a forcé à
signer là-bas non plus, donc
euh il y est allé avec euh
cette envie euh et qu'on peut
pas lui discuter d'ailleurs, de
vouloir s'imposer euh dans au
Bayern mais voilà il y a eu ce
malentendu qui fait qu'au poste
d'avant-centre c'est pas là où
il peut s'exprimer le mieux et
puis sur les côtés bah il y a
beaucoup de concurrence, il y a
Kingsel est comment, il y a
euh, euh, Serge, il y a Le Roi
Sané et donc du coup forcément
il s'est retrouvé un peu à
l'étroit en plus avec cette
blessure, en plus avec ce
changement d'entraîneur ça a
été une première euh, saison
euh, au Bayern très compliquée
euh, je crois que d'ailleurs
qu'il a pas convaincu tous les
dirigeants et que s'il y a des
dirigeants sont plus là. Oui
mais bon ils ont changé mais
bon. Et avait fait passer le
message que s'il y avait euh
quelqu'un d'intéressé euh le
Bayern était vendeur. Mais il
est plus là. Donc il est plus
là, ça veut dire que
effectivement euh Tuchel va
sûrement trouver les pour le
relancer, mais la concurrence
reste encore plus euh encore
plus euh importante qu'avant
donc euh c'est c'est pas gagné
mais il a raison moi je pense
de rester au Bayern. Rémi, euh
peut-être euh que que le fait
euh qu'il y ait eu aussi euh ce
cet entraîneur qui euh a un
schéma de jeu un peu touffu
peut-être pour euh pour pour
tout le monde et peut-être
aussi pour ses joueurs. Le fait
que ce soit Tuchel qui est
beaucoup plus carré, euh le
fait que ils l'ont finalement
dans l'effectif ce joueur et
que euh Sadio Mané c'est quand
même plutôt le le bon camarade.
Alors je sais pas si Harry Cain
il y a des rumeurs comme quoi
Hurricane est en train de
signer, est-ce qu'il y aurait
aussi une belle entente entre
ces deux? Là on aurait euh
peut-être le joueur euh
complémentaire pour euh pour
Sadio Mané? Je ne sais pas
encore parce que mais euh
lorsqu'on essaie de voir
comment Sadio Mané a réussi à
s'imposer à Liverpool on se dit
que c'est quand même difficile
de quitter de Liverpool et de
s'adapter immédiatement. Et
d'ailleurs même le vendeur ce
qui n'est pas sur ses
statistiques, curieusement on
applaudit devant au Barça.
Quand il quitte le Bayern il
plante 41 buts. Cette fois-ci
regardez ces statistiques.
C'est presque la moitié. Or,
Sadio Mané justement équipe
Liverpool lui n'est pas déjà
buteur. Parce qu'il voulait
dire que il part avec 16 buts.
Vous êtes en train de parler de
12 buts là cette saison. Oui.
Pour quelqu'un qui a été
blessé. Blessé. Il est parti de
Liverpool. C'est beaucoup 16
buts seulement, même si sur
l'ensemble de la saison,
cinquante-quatre matchs, il a
marqué vingt-trois, mais c'est
petit et d'ailleurs, durant
tout le temps qu'il a passé à
Liverpool, il n'a marqué que
120 buts. Et maintenant, vous
lui demandez d'aller remplacer.
Mais oui. Quelqu'un qui a
marqué pendant la même période,
344 buts. Et il sortait de
Dortmund, il connaissait déjà
ce ce championnat, il a planté
également 64 passes décisives.
Vous attendiez que Sadio Mané
qui arrive dans un
environnement qui déjà n'est
pas très très bon, parce qu'il
faut savoir que qui était déjà
là deux ans avant lui aussi il
est parti dans de mauvaises
conditions parce qu'il se
disputait avec euh le directeur
sportif et maintenant vous
prenez un nouvel entraîneur qui
fait aussi des essais et vous
vous retrouvez avec un Sadio
Mané que vous dites que c'est
lui qui doit porter toute cette
équipe-là. Mais non Sadio Mané
n'est pas fautive d'autant plus
que chaque quelque soit ce
qu'il est, dans un nouveau
championnat, il devrait
s'adapter. Comment peut-on
accepter un Lionel Messi de
s'adapter au Paris
Saint-Germain? Et subitement
Sadio Mané on dit mais c'est
pas possible au niveau du
Bayern. Il aurait fallu qu'il
fasse ceci qu'il fasse cela
qu'il marque des buts. Ah non
non non. Il a très bien joué,
moi je trouve et je trouve que
pour l'instant il a été blessé,
c'est qu'il a diminué ses
capacités. Mais malheureusement
quand le Bayern échoue, au lieu
de regarder tout ce qui se
passa on se cache plutôt
derrière ce que certaines
statistiques de Sergio de Sadio
Mané comme le dit un proverbe
africain quand la sauce est
gâtée on accuse la main du
lépreux. Alors ce qu'on peut se
dire euh Frédéric c'est que en
tout cas avec la sélection ils
se console très bien parce que
il y a un beau parcours euh de
du Sénégal pour ce qui est des
des matchs éliminatoires amical
euh gagné voilà par euh le
Sénégal contre le Brésil donc
euh Donc c'est un capitaine en
plus d'une sélection qui
sourit. Il a fait un très bon
match ce soir-là, euh il nous a
montré qu'il avait retrouvé
toute son intégrité physique,
et ce sera sans doute la la
clé. Si physiquement, même à 31
ans, on retrouve le le Sadio
Mané euh qui fait des
dédoublements, qui court
partout, qui est dans la
profondeur. On peut s'attendre
de sa part à à une très belle
saison. Là, c'est vrai que tout
était dans le mauvais sens,
hein, on le recrute pas, on l'a
dit. Il se blesse, euh un tel
choc euh, une déception euh. En
tout cas ils sont là euh, ils
le soutiennent hein, tous les
les auditeurs, les spectateurs
euh, les supporters bavarois
ont été très sévères avec Mané
qui outre la fatigue de la
Premier League a été victime
d'une grave blessure, ça c'est
Abdoulaye Diallo qui nous qui
nous le dit, un Sadio Mané à
soixante-quinze pour cent est
meilleur que tous les ailiers
bavaroises, ou même euh le
Catalan, Alessadio fonce sur la
Bavière, euh t'es un homme de
défi, tu vas y arriver, et
cetera, et cetera. Ouais! Donc
euh Sadio Mané, évidemment,
alors on a remarqué une chose
c'est qu'il n'a pas cédé aux
sirènes euh saoudiennes euh des
rumeurs disent qu'il aurait été
invité euh par euh le club euh
où joue Cristiano Ronaldo, le
club et que euh bon il a pas
écouté. Qui n'a pas été
contacté. C'est copain euh de
de jeu euh Edouard Mendy et euh
lui euh pas encore. D'ailleurs
il a réagi là-dessus hein. En
disant que ça ça posait pas de
problème euh même pour la
sélection de Coulibaly Mendy
partir là-bas, il dit non ils
sont dans un championnat de
plus en plus compétitif et ils
auront toujours leur place en
en sélection. Hum hum. Des
sites qui vient aux sélections.
Non mais d'accord Non il décide
pas mais en tout cas il me
connaît son âge. Non mais après
euh ce qu'on a dit sur le le
Bayern, je crois qu'on est un
peu un peu tous d'accord sur la
situation de Sadio Mané au au
Bayern. Euh maintenant ce qui
ce qui va être important
effectivement cette saison
c'est s'il y reste ce qui est
probable euh c'est sa capacité
effectivement à répondre à aux
attentes euh de Thomas Tuchel
parce que le Bayern
effectivement ben il y a une
exigence il faut toujours
gagner donc euh le le le défi
il est simple là-bas, c'est pas
la deuxième place, c'est
toujours la première. Mais le
défi est pour euh Sadio Mané,
le défi aussi est pour euh le
club euh dans son ensemble qui
doit maintenant euh se remettre
à plat recruter euh et et se
réorganiser surtout un vrai
numéro neuf. Oui et puis en
milieu de saison euh avant des
matchs euh bon on a tous vu euh
ce qui s'était passé aussi euh
changer de de de directeur avec
euh Oliver Kahn qui a été viré
donc les deux.
Dans dans la difficulté parce
que il y avait pas besoin d'y
être mais moi ce qui me dérange
c'est qu'on est en train même
de s'interroger. Ce qu'il
faudrait que Sadio Mané parte.
On parle quand même de Sadio
Mané, on parle quand même d'un
joueur qui a fait ses preuves à
Liverpool. Après comme il
disait Rémi bien sûr on a
besoin parfois on chante de
club, de ville, de pays en
plus, ben il faut un temps
d'adaptation. Il a eu la
marchande de se blesser pour
moi on devrait même pas avoir
ce genre de débat, même pas
s'interroger parce que Mané ça
reste un joueur de classement
pas sur son niveau, là on
s'interroge sur son envie et
sur son sur son futur. En tout
cas, on verra euh ce qui euh se
passera la saison prochaine
avec Sadio Mané puisqu'on sera
là. Alors on en reparlera.
Allez, continuons, on va parler
de filles. Honneur aux femmes.
Cet été, ce sont donc les
footballeuses qui animeront les
mois de juillet et d'août
puisque ce sera la neuvième
coupe du monde féminine
organisée aux antipodes. Alors
c'est en Océanie et plus
précisément en Australie et en
Nouvelle-Zélande.
Malheureusement euh Antipodes
veut aussi dire euh eh bien euh
anti horaire si on si je puisse
me permettre parce que il y
aura beaucoup de matchs en tout
cas pour ce qui est du fuseau
horaire de l'Europe et et donc
euh ce ce fuseau horaire euh
très anglais, eh bien on se
retrouvera avec des des matchs
au milieu de la nuit. En tout
cas le premier, celui de
l'ouverture se déroulera à
Auckland, en Nouvelle-Zélande
et ce sera entre justement les
Néo-zélandaises et la Norvège.
La finale le 20 août à Sydney
avec eh ben on ne sait pas qui
encore, évidemment, peut-être,
peut-être pourquoi pas le
Brésil, qui a déjà une finale
hein non mais sauf que hein,
Rémi. Faudrait vraiment euh
beaucoup de chance là. En tout
cas le Brés elles y sont, elles
sont qualifiées, elles ont déjà
disputé une finale, c'était en
2007 avec pour figure de proue
et elle est toujours là,
Martha, eh oui, euh elle a à 37
ans, elle vient de nouveau
d'être convoquée et c'est sa
sixième coupe du monde, euh une
coupe du monde où elle détient
le record, alors si on compare
et qu'on globalise avec les
hommes, c'est elle qui a marqué
le le plus de de buts, dix-sept
buts déjà classeux en est à
seize, elle a été désignée euh
six fois meilleure euh joueuse
Ballon d'or sauf que le Ballon
d'or féminin à l'époque
n'existait pas. Elle a été
médaillée d'argent deux fois
aux JO et elle a gagné trois
Copa America avec cette
sélection. Bref, une question
qu'on peut se poser, elle est
d'Éric, est-ce que Martha est
éternelle? Ben éternelle euh
dans dans quel sens? Elle sera
là trente-sept, elle sera
peut-être encore là. Elle
dispute une Coupe du monde. À
41 ans, mais est-ce qu'elle est
toujours compétitive? C'est
c'est la question qui elle
revient d'une très grosse
blessure même si elle joue aux
États-Unis. Vous vous parliez
des dix-7 buts hein en coupe du
monde euh la dernière fois
c'était en France, le mondial
209. Hum hum. Euh le sorti en
huitième de finale par les par
les Françaises. Ouais. Mais
c'est vrai que ça faisait avec
l'âge forcément ça devient de
de difficile donc elle sera là
mais est-ce que elle-même,
est-ce que la sélection
brésilienne est en mesure
d'aller loin dans ce tournoi?
Pas forcément hein, on miserait
plutôt sur euh on va en
peut-être en parler mais bon
les Américaines et puis les
nations européennes. On va voir
ça. Euh Xavier la le Brésil est
dans le groupe de la France
hein d'ailleurs euh c'est c'est
le groupe où il y aura aussi la
Jamaïque et euh le Panama euh
normalement elles doivent
sortir. Oui du Brésil qui est
en plein rajeunissement en
fait, on se souvient de Formiga
par exemple qui a joué si
longtemps et qui n'est plus euh
appelé en sélection. Marta, on
imagine qu'elle est appelée,
elle sera même peut-être pas
titulaire euh en tout cas
peut-être pas au début et et
c'est sans doute euh aussi euh
pour euh être dans le vestiaire
euh une des cadres. On on si on
regarde un peu toutes les
sélections, on les connaît pas
toutes encore, mais on on a des
des idées euh elles ont toutes
des joueuses très âgées. Euh on
va peut-être parler des
États-Unis où Meghan Rapino qui
a 38 ans. Trente-sept. Euh
trente-sept oui euh il y a le
Canada qui est championne
olympique, les championnes
olympiques à Christine Sinclair
qui a 40 ans. Euh donc euh donc
euh dans euh chez les Suédoises
vice-championne olympique et
euh donc qui ont été battus en
finale au dernier JO de Tokyo
que j'avais eu l'occasion de
commenter et puis euh qui avait
été en demi-finale de la
dernière Coupe du monde. Euh
les Suédoises il y a euh
Caroline Segueger, la milieu de
terrain qui avait quitté la
sélection, qui revient pour
cette Coupe du monde, elle a 39
ans. Donc il y a dans chaque
sélection ancienne voire deux,
voire trois euh parce que
effectivement on est sur un
sport où euh il y a une une
exigence de plus en plus grande
de compétitivité, mais il y a
aussi un réservoir de joueuses
qui est bien moindre que chez
les hommes. Donc euh et surtout
dans certains pays où
effectivement il y a pas
forcément de structures
professionnelles, donc on
s'appuie sur des filles qui ont
un peu d'expérience, qui jouent
aux États-Unis, qui jouent dans
des clubs européens, et donc
euh donc il y a il y a pas un
parfois il y a pas beaucoup
d'alternatives à ces anciennes
championnes qui restent des
références dans leur pays donc
euh Martin en est une pour le
Brésil comme Caroline Segueur
pour la Suède, comme euh Anna
Krinstein Saint-Clair pour le
Canada, comme les Américaines
dont on on va reparler. Donc
moi ça m'étonne pas en fait que
ces sélections euh soient euh
encadrées par des anciennes
parce que plus que dans le
football masculin, où il y a
moins de compétitions chez les
filles, il faut on a besoin de
ces de ces ces jeunes femmes
qui ont c'est le la sensation
qu'on a d'ailleurs euh
Benjamin, c'est que les filles
jouent plus longtemps en fait
euh Martha elle a 152
sélections pour dix9 buts, on a
Wendy Renard, j'ai regardé elle
a 141 sélections et
effectivement on pourrait comme
ça avoir beaucoup d'exemples
parce que euh le vivier est
moins grand, c'est ça? La la
concurrence est moins grande?
Oui, il y a pas beaucoup, il y
a pas beaucoup de concurrence.
Déjà on sait que dans certains
pays le football féminin
n'existe pratiquement pas. Hum
hum. Surtout euh du côté de
l'Afrique. Quand on voit donc
effectivement au niveau amateur
en plus. Oui donc on a pas
vraiment euh la possibilité de
de de l'échanger. Mais je pense
que le fait aussi d'avoir des
des joueuses comme ça,
d'expérience même si elles sont
âgées comme Marta euh
représente quand même un danger
parce que quand vous entrez sur
le terrain et que vous la voyez
elle, on connaît son histoire
hein, c'est un peu comme quand
on voit Messi euh ou Ronaldo
même malgré le rage, ça reste
des des des joueurs importants,
c'est une joueuse importante
pour son équipe, elle va
apporter, ça c'est sûr, mais
maintenant est-ce qu'elle part
pour être titulaire? Je suis
pas sûr parce que quand même
elle a elle a elle a un vécu,
elle a elle a elle a souffert
quand même d'une longue
blessure. Oui. Donc on sait pas
trop comment elle revient mais
euh la voir quand même dans
l'effectif aussi pour encadrer
les jeunes parce qu'il y a
quand même des jeunes joueurs,
des jeunes joueuses pardon qui
qui vont se montrer, ben je
trouve je trouve que oui, ça
peut être intéressant pour le
Brésil, mais ce qui va vraiment
nous nous nous nous montrer
nous définir un peu ce que le
Brésil va faire, ça sera ce
match-là contre la France. En
tout cas, les les
téléspectateurs, auditeurs, ils
connaissent le foot hein euh
Martha euh ça ça réagit, Martha
a bien géré sa carrière, c'est
une légende, nous dit archéduc
euh un autre message là Simon
Serge euh Roland Tiang, Martha
doit être reportée au Panthéon
du foot pour sa langue et riche
carrière. En tout cas, elle est
déjà au Panthéon du football
euh au Brésil hein parce que on
l'appelle la pelée euh
peut-être qu'on lui donne son
ballon d'or parce que je pense
qu'elle aura mérité, elle a pas
de chance à ce niveau hein. Et
ça
Elle a eu les deux titres de si
fort. Le ballon d'or il est
féminin il existe que depuis
trois saisons ouais je sais pas
si on aura l'occasion d'en
parler mais la la Norvège va
arriver avec Hadda alors
qu'elle s'était mise en dehors
de la sélection pendant
plusieurs années et donc cette
équipe de Norvège sera beaucoup
plus redoutable qu' ces
dernières saisons avec la seule
présence d'Adèle. Rémi, vous
allez la suivre euh avec
passion cette euh coupe du
monde féminine? J'aime les
vieilles marmites. La façon euh
vous savez non? Oui, vous savez
Jack euh bon qui peuvent avoir
une certaine longévité. Tout le
monde connaît le but de Roger,
mais il a marqué à 42 ans et et
3 mois donc la coupe du monde
hein, Roger il a marqué. Et on
connaît que euh il y a
Cristiano Ronaldo qui a quand
même joué. Plus que Martin. Il
a deux-00 à plus de 200
sélections aujourd'hui.
Deux-cents. Euh voilà
deux-cents sélections, bon. On
voit Pépé? Il a quel âge? Donc
euh lui également c'est presque
quarante ans. Il continue
encore à tenir euh la défense
du Portugal. Donc moi je crois
que quand on a une bonne
condition physique, on peut
bien avoir euh certes quelques
petites blessures, mais revenir
pour moi la seule inquiétude
c'est la longueur, la durée de
la blessure de parce que Alain
c'était le genou. Oh je connais
déjà que elle a même eu des
difficultés à revenir comme ça
parce que elle avait un énième
série elle était imbattable.
C'est-à-dire que quand elle
aligne ses ballons euh enfin
quand elle est nommée meilleure
joueuse du monde par la FIFA
c'est en cinq ans successive.
Et après il y a quand même eu
des pépères physiques. Elle a
eu à disparaître. Elle n'a eu à
récupérer qu'en 2018 où elle
est là. Exactement. Donc pour
moi, c'est là le véritable
handicap où il faut juger si
vraiment elle a eu assez de
qu'elle déclare aujourd'hui que
oui je me sens bien
physiquement mais ce n'est pas
encore des grandes
compétitions. Ce n'est que la
petite virgule que je peux
mettre en bémol. Alors euh Rémi
parmi les les nations qu'on
attend beaucoup il y a
évidemment les Américaines.
Pourquoi? Parce qu'elles ont
déjà remporté les deux éditions
justement elles sont doubles
tenantes du titre et euh Meghan
Ropino qui elle aussi donc est
vétérante euh a a parlé ces ces
derniers jours avant de de
partir euh, aux antipodes et
euh, et Meghan Rapino avec euh,
Alex Morgan et avec cette team
USA comme il se surnomme ils
ont mis carte sur table euh, on
aimerait faire le triplet. Fort
possible. Mais bon et non pas
aussi dominé en tant que lors
de la dernière Coupe du monde
où parfois ils ont beaucoup
joué de l'expérience. Et j'ai
dit d'ailleurs que quand on
essaie de regarder actuellement
certaines équipes qui sont en
train de monter, même ce Brésil
peut surprendre même si nous
reconnaissons que la France est
beaucoup plus forte que le
Brésil, enfin si on se base sur
le classement FIFA, mais quand
on voit quand même les
dernières prestations de
certaines équipes. Voilà. Je
suis inquiet. Qui pourrait euh
gêner les Américaines? Faut
rappeler une chose que vous
avez déjà une difficulté là
avec euh l'Allemagne que j'ai
vue pas impressionnant. Non.
L'Allemagne d'ailleurs a été
battue par le Brésil. Même même
même même l'Angleterre qui est
quand même championne d'Europe,
elle n'a pas pu totalement
dominer le Brésil. D'ailleurs
ça fait un but partout. Et pour
moi aujourd'hui j'ai dit je
crois que ce Brésil peut bien
rencontrer une équipe de France
qu'on attend pas. Hum hum.
Parce que l'équipe de France a
des arguments groupés, voilà.
Ça sera oui mais. Xavier. Moi
moi je j'ai comme référence le
dernier tournoi olympique. Hum.
Parce que à Toky parce que en
fait la Coupe du monde elle a
un plateau beaucoup plus large
que le tournoi euh féminin
c'est la première fois qu'il y
en a trente-deux vingt-quatre.
Donc vous avez je crois six
pays qui participent pour la
première fois, le Vietnam, les
Philippines euh il y a la
Zambie aussi euh Haïti voilà
donc c'est sympa mais ça veut
dire que le premier tour va
être un tour de de délayage et
donc ça c'est donc du coup
cette cette compétition va
vraiment commencer avec les
phases d'élimination directe
dès les huitièmes de finale et
là bah c'est ça passe ou ça
casse. Et lors des derniers
lors du dernier tournoi
olympique à à Tokyo, eh bien le
Brésil a été éliminé dès la
phase d'élimination directe euh
et non non mais on s'est
retrouvé on s'est retrouvé avec
une finale Canada Suède Canada
Suède, les Américaines ont été
éliminées euh par les
canadiennes justement euh les
les Anglaises avaient été
éliminés par les par les
Australiens. Les Anglais ont
ont gagné l'euro effectivement
mais ça veut dire que vous avez
quatre cinq équipes européennes
qui sont très compétitives par
rapport au nord américaine.
Attention elles montent en
puissance Qui a remporté deux
fois la Ligue des champions ces
trois dernières années? Il y a
les Néerlandaises qui étaient
finalistes de la dernière Coupe
du monde et qui ont été
championnes d'Europe aussi. Hum
hum. Euh donc euh les Suédoises
et puis euh et puis faut pas
faut pas oublier nos petites
Françaises parce que je pense
que elles ont encore le
potentiel pour euh et
notamment
mais bon il y a un réservoir ce
qui est ce qui est intéressant
et ça nous ramène un peu au
Brésil c'est que fut une époque
où on venait on faisait venir
des joueuses brésiliennes dans
les clubs européens parce
qu'elles avaient ce cette
capacité à jouer très
naturellement euh comme les
hommes d'ailleurs la plupart du
temps dans dans les rues euh or
aujourd'hui les les pays
européens ont beaucoup
structuré leur formation des
jeunes filles euh en France, en
Angleterre notamment de la FIFA
hein qui encourage beaucoup ça.
Absolument, donc aujourd'hui on
a des clubs européens qui font
beaucoup moins appel qu'avant
aux aux aux équipes, aux
joueuses des autres continents.
Hum hum. Et euh qui même en
exporte parfois notamment aux
États-Unis. Éloge quoi Dieu
nous dit, moi je vois la France
et l'Angleterre, voilà. Bon.
Ouais ben la Suède hein. La
France et la France je crois
cinquième hein? Ouais non il y
a cinquième La Suède a une très
très bonne équipe, ça fait deux
fois de suite qu'il de peu une
un couronnement euh elles ont
été troisièmes de la dernière
Coupe du monde, deux médailles
d'argent au dernier Jeux
Olympiques, euh elles ont euh
des filles devant qui sont très
très fortes, notamment Kosova
Aslanni qui est d'origine
Kosova comme son prénom
l'indique, qui a joué au Paris
Saint-Germain, euh Stinia Black
Sténius devant, euh euh donc
c'est ces ces défis qui sont
qui en vrais collectifs et
elles vont vouloir enfin gagner
quelque chose. En tout cas, les
Françaises partent avec euh
Hervé Renard, hein, on l'a tous
vu et suivi, on verra bien euh
si euh le meneur d'homme sera
aussi un meneur euh femmes du
côté de l'Australie et de la
Nouvelle-Zélande. Allez, on
continue, on va parler de cette
saison euh, une saison pas
comme les autres.
C'est terminé! Et c'est fini!
Il va rester là. C'est terminé!
C'est terminé Une saison donc
s'achève euh à Radio Foot mais
aussi une saison euh où s'est
qui s'est achevée dans les
grands championnats européens.
Et on le sait tous, on en a
beaucoup parlé, c'est une
saison qui était complètement
différente parce que pour la
première fois, il y a eu une
coupe du monde qui a scindé
cette saison en deux parties.
C'était la Coupe du monde au
Qatar bien sûr qui a coupé euh
les championnats en deux et on
a bien vu euh le résultat. On a
bien vu les effets dans tout ça
Est-ce que euh on on on a on a
dégagé plusieurs euh choses
importantes dans cette saison,
il y a eu euh le Ballon d'or
pour Karim Benzema bien sûr,
ensuite on a eu les Argentins
sacrés champions du monde, il y
a eu le triplé de de Manchester
City avec euh ces ces trois
titres euh qui étaient euh la
la cup anglaise, le championnat
d'Angleterre et la Ligue des
champions. Et puis on a aussi
un fait c'est que Cristiano
Ronaldo d'abord et ensuite euh
Lionel Messi ont quitté le
championnat euh, les
championnats européens eux qui
euh, ont euh, si longtemps
donné le la. Peut-être aussi
maintenant l'Arabie Saoudite
qui qui brouille les cartes qui
est est rentrée dans le jeu et
qui euh, change euh, peut-être
la règle du jeu, ça on ne le
sait pas encore, on le mesurera
sans doute mieux l'année
prochaine. D'abord sur le fait
euh, et là je m'adresse aux
professionnels à à Benjamin
Mokamjou cette cette Coupe du
monde qui est tombée en milieu
de la saison et qui finalement
a vraiment fait euh, dans dans
certains pays d'Amérique du Sud
on a le le tournoi d'ouverture
et le tournoi de fermeture hein
euh à Pertola et Claussou là
comme en en Argentine. Est-ce
qu'on a ressenti ça pour la
première fois aussi en Europe
selon vous euh Benjamin? Oui on
on on l'a ressenti, on l'a
ressenti aussi euh sur les
joueurs physiquement parce
qu'il y a beaucoup de joueurs
aux sorties de la Coupe du
monde qui ont eu du mal à à
repartir. Mais euh je pense que
tout le monde hein était
préparé, ça faisait des années
que on savait que la Coupe du
monde allait se jouer au Qatar
et que euh euh on pouvait pas
la jouer au mois de juin, parce
qu'au mois de juin, c'est
impossible de de de jouer au
football là-bas, il fait
tellement chaud. Donc on l'a
ramené au mois de de décembre,
ben tout le monde le savait au
mois de novembre, tout le monde
le savait, mais effectivement
ça a eu de l'impact, ça a eu ça
a eu de l'impact sur beaucoup
d'équipes d'ailleurs. On a eu
une sensation de de championnat
euh en deux parties. Oui, c'est
en deux parties et puis euh on
a on a tellement répété ici, il
y a eu des joueurs qui se sont
vraiment préparés pour la
jouer, pour la gagner cette
coupe du monde, qu'au final
quand ils ont gagné, ils ont eu
du mal à à revenir. Mais je
pense qu'au-delà de tout ça euh
euh quand on voit les équipes
quand même qui sont restées
constantes tout au long de la
saison, par exemple, je pense à
Manchester City euh qui a pu
euh sur la fin, sur le fil euh
euh Arsenal, c'est parce que
aussi ils avaient un effectif
conséquent. Toutes les autres
équipes, moi je parle je pense
de d'Arsenal effectif, okay,
bel effectif, mais il y avait
pas assez de joueurs pour
pouvoir euh pour pouvoir
tourner, et puis ben il y a
d'autres équipes, voilà,
malheureusement, qui ont connu
des blessures, qui ont connu
des méformes, mais je pense que
oui, cette Coupe du monde euh,
elle va rester longtemps parce
qu'on on on va en parler avec
la victoire de l'Argentine,
mais aussi des clubs en ont sou
Rémi, est-ce que pour vous euh
cette première euh Coupe du
monde par ailleurs? Alors elle
coupait la la saison en deux
mais organisée dans un pays euh
arabe, organisé sur la
péninsule arabie, tournée
beaucoup vers l'Asie, ou
lorsqu'on y était, on a
beaucoup vu, hein, Frédéric,
c'est c'est ces personnes qui
venaient du Pakistan, du Népal,
euh du Liban, enfin cette
partie du monde. Est-ce que
pour vous, ce c'est une
réussite malgré euh tout,
peut-être, malgré les
conséquences sur les
championnats? Le réussite de
l'argent. Parce que première
des choses,
calendrier et puis on est quand
même parti dans un pays où on
nous parlait tantôt des droits
de l'homme qui sont mis sous le
boiseau mais là où tout le
monde a fermé les yeux, pouvoir
de l'argent. Et puis on est
arrivé dans cette Coupe du
monde là où bien évidemment les
joueurs on a pu le constater
non plus jouer après la Coupe
du monde dont leur objectif
était juste d'aller dans cette
Coupe du monde et là et
finalement après ça a eu des
résultats beaucoup plus
négatifs sur certains clubs
d'ailleurs. On a pu voir un
messie qui métamorphosé,
c'est-à-dire que des super
lions, ils n'étaient plus comme
autant à Paris. Maintenant,
quand on essaie de regarder
est-ce qu'il y a eu une coupe
du monde euh en hiver? Selon
vous? Euh je ne sais pas s'il
faut répéter une coupe du monde
en hiver parce que justement
par rapport euh à ce que on a
pu constater là-bas euh on ne
sait pas si c'était l'hiver ou
l'été, c'était de toutes les
façons l'été. Mais avec des
avec des avec des climats et
euh c'est-à-dire vous sortez de
la à l'extérieur vous brûlez.
C'était quand même un peu euh
c'est-à-dire que même sur le
homéopathie. Ils les ont pas
utilisés euh moi j'ai été en
plus dans les stades euh bon
j'ai assisté au premier mois de
l'Argentine, c'est vrai qu'il y
en avait mais à la fin le le
climat il était assez bon pour
jouer au football. Mais moi je
pense que je suis pas d'accord
avec toi Rémi c'est que il faut
que. Ou pas finalement. Moi je
pense que honnêtement il faut
la coupe du monde n'appartient
à personne, elle n'appartient
pas qu'en euros.
Oui mais il faut que tout le
monde, tous les pays qui sont
capables de l'organiser
il y avait l'unité de lieu
hein, on était à Doha où euh
tout se passait dans un
périmètre de dix, bien parce
que c'est la seule coupe du
monde où on a pu l'organiser
dans un pays c'est le pouvoir
oui bah oui. En tout cas euh
euh on on peut parler aussi
peut-être euh du du triplé de
de Manchester City euh Xavier?
Oui parce que c'est c'est un
peu le contrecoup en fait de
cette coupe du monde oui de
cette quand euh Annie a évoqué
les thèmes non mais c'est c'est
un grand succès, autant cette
coupe du monde effectivement on
peut discuter un certain nombre
de choses, autant cette saison
finalement euh c'est
l'aboutissement d'un projet euh
construit depuis des années par
euh euh Ferane euh Soriano par
et par Pegg Guardiola à la tête
de Manchester City. Donc c'est
l'aboutissement d'un projet qui
est effectivement, il y a aussi
de l'argent, c'est vrai, mais
il y a surtout une logique
sportive Et cette logique
sportive, elle est récompensée
avec cette victoire en Ligue
des champions, qui a mis un peu
de temps à venir, mais ça a été
le cas aussi Chelsea avant. Ils
ont mis du temps avant de la
gagner. Donc ils ont eu euh
effectivement toutes ces années
pour travailler ces années de
persévérance, rester fidèles à
un schéma de jeu, à à recruter
des joueurs qui intègrent un
système et non pas des stars
qu'on essaye de faire jouer
ensemble comme le euh ou qui et
qui n'y arrivent pas comme le
PSG il prend des joueurs qu'il
fait devenir des stars, c'est
ça la différence. Parce que
quand il recrute Aymeric
Laporte, quand il prend Riyad
Marhez, quand il prend Bernardo
Silva, c'est pas des stars.
Qui avait éliminé s'il te plaît
c'est l'aboutissement
Zidane
une équipe qui avait été
construite par Pep Bouardiola
et il arrive à gagner quelque
chose. au Là il a réussi et
c'est ça et le fait marquant de
cette saison, c'est
qu'effectivement un club
nouveau qui n'avait pas une
grande histoire ce trophée
finalement, y arrive en se
fixant des objectifs sur la
durée et en restant fidèle à un
projet de jeu. Mais mes petits
bémols que cette saison de
Ligue des Champions, oui City
euh arrive enfin à la gagner
mais par rapport à l'année
précédente et là c'est les
conséquences de la Coupe du
monde. Moi je trouve qu'on est
un peu restés sur notre fin,
huitième de finale, quart de
finale, demi-finale. Qu'est-ce
qui reste? Bon il y avait euh
oui les trois clubs italiens
euh certes Naples mais des
grands retournements de
situation, des matchs fous, on
en a pas vraiment eu sans doute
que c'était aussi l'effet coupe
du monde. Rémi, alors puisque
on parlait euh vous voulez
parler de Zidane mais moi je me
disais on pourrait peut-être
parler du Ballon d'or de de
Karim Benzema, parce que par
rapport à d'autres joueurs
peut-être, il avait 34 ans
quand il l'a reçu et on a la la
la sensation d'autant
maintenant qu'il est parti euh
jouer lui euh à Jeddah euh en
Arabie Saoudite, que c'était
une consécration d'un joueur et
et et sur d'autres ça a pas été
le cas. On avait Messi, on
avait Cristiano, on avait même
Modric qui était euh au à un
moment top de leur carrière, et
lui ça a été pratiquement la
récompense d'une carrière
entière. Ouais et surtout euh
la preuve que c'est un joueur
mature qui a accepté toutes les
critiques, qui a dépassé toutes
les limites et qui n'étaient
pas attendues. Il faut quand
même se dire que lorsque
Benzema dans l'ombre. Oui. Il a
été beaucoup dans l'ombre de
Cristiano Ronaldo et puis quand
Cristiano Ronaldo part le Real
ne mise pas sur Benzema, même
mise sur son remplaçant de le
remplaçant de Ronaldo. C'est
qui? Eden Hazard. Quand on
parle de Sadio Mané quand même
n'oublions pas que Eden Hazard
lui avec le Real Madrid ça pour
que 300 millions pour une
première saison il a marqué un
but, une deuxième saison, il a
marqué un but et deux deux
passes décisives et qui sont
tout simplement
lui au lieu de se dire que je
parce qu'on veut donner tout à
Eden Hazard recruté à 16
millions lui il s'est mis
plutôt à la disposition de ce
jeune collectif il a réussi à
faire que Vinicius comprenne le
jeu, il est devenu le véritable
patron même du milieu de
terrain et malgré ses problèmes
en France où il était le seul
joueur grand attaquant à ne pas
être appelé en sélection, il a
continué à travailler.
Rappelez-vous que ce Benzema
est en concurrence avec parti,
rappelez-vous qu'il était en
concurrence avec Higuen, où est
parti? Et finalement ce
Benzema-là qui était taxé des
chats? Par Mourinho est devenu.
Non. Un véritable lion.
D'habitude Mourinho euh tu lui
tresses des louanges là euh tu
le critiques. Ah oui mais il a
fouetté Benzema et Benzema a
compris le message qui tombe
euh Prince qui nous dit euh
Benjamin Moukanjo ne te laisse
pas influencer par Rémi.
Non c'est un lion et un
proverbe africain qui dit quand
tu manges la tête de lion tu
n'as pas peur de ses dents une
chose encore dans ces thèmes
qu'on avait euh, un peu euh, le
le départ de Messi et Cristiano
pour vous, est-ce que euh, ils
sont partis physiquement, mais
est-ce qu'ils étaient déjà
partis d'une certaine façon?
Non, je pense que déjà c'est
euh, c'est une page un peu de
l'histoire du football qui qui
qui va ils étaient partis d'une
certaine façon depuis qu'il y
avait plus de confrontations en
Ligue A? Non pas du tout parce
que malgré tout ça reste quand
même deux deux vrais champions
euh, Ronaldo quand il décide de
partir à la Juve il part avec
l'ambition de de gagner la
Champions League, de gagner
plein de trophées même quand il
retourne à à voilà, ils ont
toujours ces joueurs-là qui ont
gagné pendant toute leur
carrière, ils ont toujours
cette envie, cette cette faim
de gagner. Bah aujourd'hui bien
sûr qu'ils ont quand même un
âge assez avancé, comme Messi
en plus il a dit j'ai tout
fait, j'ai tout gagné, ben ils
partent avec le sentiment du
devoir accompli. Et voilà,
maintenant il y a des jeunes
joueurs comme Mbappé, comme
Island, comme comme Vinicius,
qui sont là, qui doivent
prendre la relève, mais c'est
clair que cette concurrence
qu'on a vécue pendant 15 ans,
je crois, ben on la verra plus.
Voilà pour ce qui est donc de
cette euh saison euh retenir
euh, moi je retiendrai euh, le
scénario absolument euh,
incroyable de la finale de la
coupe du monde. On croyait
qu'on avait tout vécu en
19quatre-vingt-deux quand on
revoyait les images et qu'on se
disait c'est pas possible. Pas
passé là. Euh, alors
quatre-vingt-deux ils peuvent
passer mais alors je crois de
deux-mille-vingt-deux euh, oui
exactement euh, je crois que
c'est c'est presque plus ne
remuez pas le couteau dans la
blé s'il vous plaît Frédéric.
Allez, on va vers les cartons.
Carton jaune sort un carton
jaune. Oh carton rouge, carton
rouge. Dans la confusion.
Carton vert. Rien à dire. À
vous tout de suite aussitôt euh
chers euh auditeurs internautes
euh sélectionnés par David
Fitzel, vous allez voir euh on
vous remercie parce que vous
êtes déjà presque en vacances
et vous nous encouragez.
Bonjour au Sénégal. Je voudrais
donner un carton vert à une
dame pas comme les autres. Dans
un homme meilleur
Comme le dit on proverbe
sénégalais un radio foot
international sans c'est comme
un classique ou sans but.
Café de sport, vous êtes
meilleur, vous êtes les
meilleurs. Café de sport. Je
vous donne le carton vert radio
foot
nous les on a pris. Tu es notre
idole, tu es une légende pour
nous, tu es notre icône. Quand
on aime quelqu'un, il faut le
célébrer de son vivant. Didier
Drogba. Nous les Béninois, nous
t'aimons. Nous serons toujours
derrière toi. Didier Drogba,
les Béninois ont besoin
victoire. Bonne soirée! Salut,
salut RFI, c'est depuis la
ville de Kinshasa. Euh je vous
donne vous tous un carton à
vous tous, à toutes des
personnes qui constituent cette
équipe merveilleuse, cohérente,
solide de notre émission
préférée Adofoot International,
vous nous faites chavirer
toutes les semaines, notamment
à madame Annie Gasnet, ta belle
voix me manque salut Radio
Foot, salut Annie, c'est
démocratique du Congo, mon
carton est vert pour Edmonton,
les joueurs coréens, lui qui
avait ce mercredi trente-et-un
ans et dès ce jeudi les joueurs
a désormais 30 ans d'âge. Pour
lui et bravo pour
leur nouveau format concernant
merci bonne émission. Salut
c'est Sénégal fidèle auditeur
de Radio Foot depuis 12 ans.
Alors vous voyez que tout ce
que je porte aujourd'hui c'est
du rouge y compris la montre et
la bague rouge de suggestion.
Alors allégation et ton équipe
nos foyers vous pas que nos
cartons qui passent chaque
semaine sont aussi riches les
uns que les autres. Je vous
suggère de donner une
récompense aux trois meilleurs
cartons de la semaine histoire
d'augmenter la popul l'heure de
foot sur le continent africain.
Émission qui est très suivie
sur le continent. Salut à tous.
Bonjour Radio Foot. Depuis la
Guinée Conakry. Je te donne un
carton vert à mon équipe
nationale de Guinée U 23 qui
fait une belle canne après son
deuxième match. Donc je peux
notre fédération de musée
sociale pour 2024. Ciao.
Bonjour à toute l'équipe Radio
Foot International depuis
Abidjan Côte d'Ivoire. Veuillez
Pour toute l'équipe de Radio
Foot International pour cette
saison que vous nous avez
encore donnée. Et je vous dis
comme ça bravo et merci. Car
vous méritez encore ces
vacances et pourquoi pas la
Côte d'Ivoire pour une
destination car je suis prêt à
vous accueillir. Bonsoir café
sport Radio Ford pour ce
dernier numéro de Café Sport de
la saison. J'aimerais attribuer
un carton rouge à la fédération
marocaine de football ainsi
quà la vie de Guinée. Mar le
match d'ouverture de la de la
c'est vraiment une honte pour
le football africain. On joue
carton vert à jouer au foot
international et puis merci de
nous avoir informé durant toute
la saison sportive. Pour nous
autres qui ne sommes plus au
monde francophone, c'est un
outil aussi pour nous de
restaurer notre euh et
vocabulaire en français.
Vraiment pour ce petit temps de
trêve vous allez vraiment
vraiment nous manquer. Bonjour
Radio Foot International. C'est
moi. En RDC. Carton vert à
Annie Gasni Xavier Barry,
Frédéric Guérin, David Finzel,
Alejandro Valente Caroline
Paris, oh non, elle c'est
priorité santé, peu importe,
des bonnes vacances à vous
tous, vous formez une très
bonne équipe et on vous revoit
à bientôt, beaucoup plus en
forme. Merci. Voyez, je vous
avais dit hein, ils sont
compréhensifs et ils savent que
on sera euh, en vacances, je
voudrais répondre à certains
euh, pour le palmarès euh, on
met pas de un, deux, trois,
mais euh, David Finzel
sélectionne les les cartons
donc on sélectionne les
meilleurs, vous inquiétez pas.
Euh pour ce qui est de la Côte
d'Ivoire, c'est une suggestion
euh mais ça sera euh une
réalisation il y a une certaine
canne au mois de janvier
prochain et Radio Foot devrait
y être aussi donc euh si on
vous fait chavirer euh de
plaisir euh chaque week-end euh
c'est encore mieux pour nous.
Allez euh les cartons eh bien
euh Benjamin je pense que vous
êtes dans le ton de de nos
auditeurs. Oui je savais pas
regarder avant mais bon en tout
cas mon carton il il est vert à
toute l'équipe et puis bien sûr
à l'équipe de Café des Sports,
pour moi c'était une grande
première cette saison euh, j'ai
vécu euh, de belles émissions
avec euh, beaucoup de beaucoup
d'activités ce duel euh,
infinissable mais en tout cas
dans toujours dans le respect
dans le dans la bonne humeur en
tout cas merci c'est un plaisir
pour moi et hâte de vous
retrouver merci beaucoup
Benjamin et euh, on vous
retrouve euh, la saison
prochaine on on vous réserve
déjà. Allez euh, votre carton
Rémi. Vert. Allez entre
Camerounais hein on vous passe
le relais. Alors je suis très
content, je suis heureux parce
que c' un pays que je vois
l'évolution du football au
Niger. Donc le carton Verdon
c'est pour les U 23 du Niger
qui bien évidemment ont tenu en
échec à la CAN l'Égypte et puis
ont battu le Gabon par un but à
zéro vous vous rendez compte.
C'est ce Gabon qui a éliminé le
Cameroun. Donc finalement on se
disait que le Gabon c'est une
équipe très forte et tout et
tout et tout et tout. Le Gabon
rentre avec zéro point mais
c'est pas possible. Il y a un
problème africain qui dit
finalement que le crapaud n'est
devant la grenouille. Xavier.
Ces équipes-là on les verra aux
Jeux Olympiques de Paris l'an
prochain, enfin les quatre qui
iront en demi-finale. Exact. Au
moins trois. Euh moi carton
vert, il y a notre euh auditeur
au Bénin qui saluait Didier
Drogba, moi je voudrais saluer
Didier Drogba aussi et Jérémie
Gitap qui est le président de
la FIFPRO Afrique et qui vont
lancer ce lundi une campagne
euh attention aux faux agents
pour euh démystifier
effectivement toutes ces
tentations que dont sont
victimes de trop nombreux
jeunes joueurs africains. Et
donc ils vont les mettre en
garde contre ces personnes qui
leur vendent du rêve et qui
ensuite euh les envoient en
Europe n'importe où, dans des
bidonvilles, ils se retrouvent
de pizza est très loin du rêve
d'être footballeur
professionnel qui les fait
vivre. On en parlera d'ailleurs
plus longuement à la rentrée
dans Radio Foot International.
Euh notre carton, le carton de
Radio Foot euh est rouge et
blanc et il va au matelassier
de Madrid. L'Atlético a fait
voter ses hein vous le savez,
ce sont les actionnaires euh
abonnés, 60 000 personnes qui
ont répondu à l'appel du vote
de la direction et qui veulent
le retour de leur vieille
écusson, l'historique, celui où
il y avait des couleurs,
notamment très jaune autour et
l'ours, le fameux ours qui
mange des mûres sur l'arbre,
des arbous d'ailleurs pardon je
crois. Ce sont des donc euh
bravo à la démocratie et au
référendum euh dans les clubs.
Frédéric, c'est vous qui fermez
le banc. Hou là! Carton vert,
alors déjà pour remercier tous
nos auditeurs, téléspectateurs
sans qui nous ne serions rien,
merci pour tout pour tous les
messages, l'équipe du Café des
Sports et Carton vert aux
joueurs, nos amis, les
footballeurs qu'ils profitent
de leurs vacances Bonnes
vacances à ou que vous soyez,
on va les retrouver aussi. On
va faire pareil comme dans deux
trois semaines. Il y en a qui
sont affutés hein. On voit les
photos, ben vous vous enverrez
la vôtre Benjamin? Affûté.
C'est la fin donc de ce café
des sports, c'est la fin de
cette saison avec vous tous sur
RFI et sur euh France 24 ainsi
que Facebook Live. À l'année
prochaine. Merci à tous.